okay it's Friday we're back to business
as usual after our hundredth episode
yeah we're gonna do this one sober yeah
it's very early in the morning it's
actually just a movie review we're gonna
do the running man I haven't seen the
running man it's really since I was in
my probably teens yeah the same I hadn't
seen it for a long time I got it on DVD
because the blu-rays were so expensive
on this one I couldn't find it I wonder
why I don't know it's good so it's
almost a forgotten movie it is kind of
it's like one of the ones that doesn't
really get brought up a lot in the
Arnold Schwarzenegger Canada yeah I
remember I mean I really liked it when I
was young you know so I went back and
watched it again and I kind of expected
it to be pretty bad no it was pretty
damn good yeah it's a lot better than
our it's like super cheesy and yet
over-the-top eighties kind of way but
that's the top yeah that's kind of what
you want for us is like an 80s sort of
action movie mom is really good at that
that's you know he was he was a
specialist it kind of a fun goofy tone
to it it's almost kind of like
mythological it's not supposed to be you
know Rhea
but behind the movie you know there's a
lot of themes that turned up to kind of
come true and it kind of first saw the
rise of reality TV you know things like
Survivor and American Gladiator I think
actually American Gladiator was it was a
ripoff of I think American Gladiators
pretty much straight up took the idea
from this movie and richard dawson you
know and some of his lines in the movie
foresaw a time when the government would
use kind of like state-run media to
propagandize people and and to control
them and that kind of not only did it
kind of come to pass that had been going
on it's just that we didn't know about
it well there have been other movies
like this kind of you know it's
basically you're straight up eighties
dystopia kind of movie they've had like
death race and you know exactly battle
royale and that kind of stuff it was on
the same vein yeah yeah so this is think
of this as kind of like an 80s version
of like The Hunger Games or something
it's a similar kind of theme yeah The
Hunger Games is definitely a ripoff of
this yeah but like I said there's a lot
of there's a whole sub-genre of
dystopian fiction which this you have
comes from and because this is based on
a Stephen King
look that he wrote under a pseudonym
it's suitable for the show so we're
gonna go ahead and do this one yeah
because it's like an action movie it's
also kind of like a horror movie got it
yeah this is one that I saw it came out
the film came out in 1987 and this was
one that I saw a lot like back in the
late 80s because it was on I had it on
VHS they used to play it on cable like
all the time and I remember really
digging it like I said it's sort of an
action it's mostly an action movie it
has a little bit of sci-fi horror
crossover there's some gore in it which
I liked but then there's kind of much
though not a lot I mean that dudes had
blowing up and stuff that was kind of
neat and most of the gorse kind of a
long shot was far away yes that looks
real that was my favorite you look real
that it really did because as you said
when we were watching it cuz this was
made in 1987 right it's like but it
looked like his head blew up while he
was running yeah I'm like how did they
do that
you must been hunched over and a head if
they really blew that dudes head up fake
upper torso on that guy sorry Chico that
was a character just the way the way
they edited it you know so quickly it
was hard to tell exactly what happened
but it did look like oh it really did
look like a guy was running and then his
head explodes yeah and they got a lot of
uh kind of like an all-star cast if
you've been around for a long time you
see the guy from alien is in it the
black guy what's his name you know well
hey why don't they freeze him why don't
be freezing what was that character's
name I forgot doesn't matter but that
guy's in it
Richard Dawson's in it which was he was
the best richard Dawson was the best
part this act he was the most inspired
casting choice probably of all 80s
action movies because if for those of
you that are too young to remember yeah
richard dawson was an actual game show
host very famous for hosting family feud
back yeah yeah and it was awesome and he
was kind of a sleazy drunk yeah yeah is
is awesome
his career went way back into the
seventies yeah I'd be a little kid not
watch Dawson and Hollywood at that time
would pump out all these game shows like
Joker's wild and a liar's club and you
know Hollywood Squares that I love those
yeah they're a cool
it was just the regulars celebrities who
were just famous for being famous they
were yeah celebrities and they would
just be on these all these game shows
and they didn't have normal jobs of
course and they would probably film
[ __ ] seven or eight or those episodes
a day and they'd probably do them all in
about a month period and make a bunch of
cash and you could tell that they got
sick of working all day and all night
long because they were loaded they were
yeah they were and I could see him
reaching down to grab a drink yeah it
later on curry were just like we do but
yeah hilarious
and something really good and Dawson was
a host on some of them and one of them
was family feud's yeah and I remember
being a kid him just be loaded putting
the moves on people's wives Oh for real
people's daughters in the middle of
family feud and there was a couple times
I could have swore he reached out down
and grabbed some ass I'm sure he did it
when you really couldn't tell you
couldn't see it because it was kind of a
close-up you can see his shoulder kind
of dip down anything woman's face turn
over head and he'd be like looking at
the camera because you know baby you
know he's got and I think he'd have a
drink in his hand at times didn't he I
was gonna be dinner not or he would just
just look like he had he should have had
a drink in his head yeah baby that's
movement behind that little [ __ ]
Flass that wasn't a pulpit yeah it was
like a little podium that's a podium he
can't drink in there he probably did
there was like a little shelf and you
can go on YouTube and look up the liar's
club and that was such a good yeah we
watched a bunch of those on you and you
can just tell you know Joker's wild I
love Joker's wild yeah it was good too
but the buyers club and you can see all
the episodes of that on YouTube and and
once a Buddy Hackett that dude is just
snockered he's just loaded oh yeah and
what with Larry Hagman wasn't lit wasn't
it wasn't Larry Hagman oh that's right I
think he was just a button or I'm it was
the blonde guy from Hogan's Heroes that
wasn't Larry Hagman oh [ __ ]
yeah you know he was in there and he
would just be just trashed yeah and that
was a fun game because they would hand
over a mysterious object and they would
lie their asses off to explain what that
object was and the contestants had to
figure out who was telling who was
telling the truth and he was lying yeah
who was lying that was a funny ash I get
a bit still funny this is awesome and
they could tell that it was happening
like a dingy dingy kind of 1970s
Hollywood studio that wasn't much bigger
than a garage it probably was a garage
Parker it was funny well yeah so I was
gonna say that like you have we went off
on there's just just to say that they
cast richard dawson who was an actual
game show host
yeah and they put him in this to be a
game show host like the sleaziest sleaze
bag no game show so he's basically
playing playing an evil version of
himself he's like a slightly more evil
version of himself and he is amazing he
is like the best part of this [ __ ]
movie yeah and what it is is his show
basically has government contracts to
publicly execute enemies of the state
before a lot before a live audience
there yeah amorous everywhere and they
have kind of a dystopian area of the
city I think they said what was it 200
city squares something like that yeah
that's like the game ignore the game
area with a bunch of cameras and there
and they have a bunch of people working
in there you know with colourful armor
and motorcycles and you know dirt bikes
to chase people along certain routes
then they have these things called
stalkers who are like these celebrity
killers they're kind of like each one of
them kind of has their own name and
their own equipment and they run the
stalkers down try to kill they got name
what's up zero zero Dynamo Dynamo yeah
yeah you know Jesse the body adventure
was one way of losing he's like a
retired one yet he's Captain freedom III
there's kind of like a very good kept
freedom he had hair in this movie is
weird but yeah he's actually not in it a
great deal the he's like turns up at the
beginning like in an aerobics workout
video is funny and then
jiae's he possibly can with the aerobics
remember that seriously yeah he's trying
to look like Captain America and Richard
Simmons had a lovechild is exactly like
that yeah that's what they're a spoof
and I remember at the time because I saw
this in a theater when it came out yeah
well you know we're my buddies at laughs
and United again just like yeah the
whole premise of this movie it's
actually set in 2009 2009 more than it
is I think the beginning is 27 27 but
then but then Ben Richards who is Arnold
Schwarzenegger character he gets pretty
much flamed yeah for a crime unit like
they used some creative editing to make
it look like he killed a bunch of people
yeah which that's kind of what one of
the narratives of the movie is that
they're showing you how easy it is to
manipulate the audience by editing
things to create a narrative and in my
deluxe DVD version of this they actually
have like some extras on there about the
show survivor and the people that
actually made the show survivor and how
reality TV really isn't real they would
film people do it all kinds of stuff and
they would tell him to act out and then
they would edit it in a certain way to
make any kind of narrative that they
wanted well yeah I mean there's actually
there's been a few documentaries out
about this about how I mean obviously
everybody knows now that reality TV is
[ __ ] it's like you know what I mean
they can edit to make what's fake TV
well and honestly most of the people
other than a couple of the early reality
TV shows when it wasn't really that big
of a genre later on you got people that
were looking to make a big break so all
the people on there that were trying out
for the show were actors or actress
struggling actors and actresses and you
know they wanted to get famous there's
like oh well I'll be on a reality show
and then I'll get famous and so a lot of
them are already so they're already
playing a character the reality show can
producers are like well we need a person
that does this and a person we need a
[ __ ] we need a villain and we need as
for that in the other so they cast for
particular personality types and then
they've done things like liquor and
people up they tell people lies about
other people on the show
yes they get them to conflict it's the
same thing they do in the the green room
of like Jerry Springer and stuff like
that like you hey this person said you
were fat so like when they come out in
CDF same thing they do in goth clubs
worldwide so then when they come out on
stage they're like right so this movie
kind of predicted that but I mean the
book came first obviously this one is
much more based around this is this
movie I have to say is 80s as [ __ ] yeah
yeah they have like the the Running Man
game yeah show actually has like a bunch
of like solid gold dancers is like
[ __ ] shiny workout just moving
everything this movie is a hipsters
paradise you know what's funny is that I
saw comments and some reviews like I'm
not on Rotten Tomatoes about how cheesy
and fake look and the sets were and I
was like no that was just a tease that's
what everything looked like that
wherever you win that's that's how cheap
and cheesy [ __ ] well if everything was
cheapest [ __ ] it was like crappy stuff
and everything was painted crappy and
that's yeah yeah it's 80s as [ __ ] but in
a way that kind of works cuz it kind of
goes with the whole I mean you're you're
watching what is supposed to be a TV
game show yeah in 2019 in 2019 in a
dystopian dystopia yeah like I said it's
like the whole [ __ ] everybody's like
in workout gear and stuff it's the
craziest thing and then you know there's
the whole thing with Arnold
Schwarzenegger is like really grown were
they one-liners like after he Hill some
of the stalkers new stuff like that like
it you know he cuts a guy in half and
then he's like oh you had to split you
know that was the genre and that's what
the audience wanted at the time I saw
this in the theater and I was in my late
teens it hit the spot this is exactly
what we wanted to see at that time yeah
so this was a well made movie well
written for the time younger people they
see these movies very much out of
context the cultural context is very
different all right
boy that's cheesy now we would love that
yeah we love that back in the
days but I think she'll do but I think
the cheesiness is part of its charm it
was all on purpose I mean and [ __ ] man
over [ __ ] Dweezil Zappa 's and that's
play like a revolutionary with a beret
and everything yeah and also mick
fleetwood is in this as the leader of
the resistance
yeah well and this is something I love
about 80s movies and like you said I
think the reason and I think you said
this the reason you like a lot of 80s
movies is because of their optimism and
something yeah
the thing that's awesome about a lot of
these eighties particularly like 80s
dystopian movies yeah it's like all we
have to do is hack into the TV's Network
and tell them the truth tell them the
truth
and everything will get better and I'm
like ah thank you think anything's gonna
check it right it's not just by like
yeah we did it you know what I mean but
that's kind of a cool thing about it the
idea of an 80s movies was you had kind
of like especially harlots war scenarios
an epitome of it you had kind of an
idealized heroic character yeah you had
a diverse cast trying to get through and
this is I think it's hilarious today
they're always talking about diversity
in films these films were always diverse
you can go back a long time you could
see diversity you didn't really have to
force it they just did that
automatically back then anyway you have
a diverse cast it goes through all this
hardship they resolve the conflict
everything's good and the movie ends on
this high note so when you left the
theater you would walk out into the
night or the daylight depending on what
time you saw the I saw the theater which
is an experience I think a lot of young
people really don't do anymore which is
going to theaters you come out and you
had an optimistic feeling and you got in
your car you drove around bye that was
great we can do it we can do it man yeah
it was almost kind of like a pseudo
religious experience actually coming out
of this there being in the theater and
coming out yeah I like coming out of a
church it kind of and actually I just
this just occurred to me with this sort
of like the ending of this kind of
reminds me of the ending of they live
where it's just kind of like yeah you
know we we took over the the TV station
and you know we told them we told the
world everything and all this I think
was a theme happening over and over you
yeah that happened a lot of 80s movies
like I said particularly it was you know
it was a deist [ __ ] to have a positive
uplifting end to the movie there wasn't
any of that like subversion of
expectations they need that
post-modernism really in the endings
they were
traditional and they were kind of
uplifting at the end yeah they
definitely had a formula particularly
action movies because I think people
would they went into it knowing what to
expect and it's like you if you tried to
do something different everybody like
yeah looking back on it you know with
the whole theater culture had grown up
in it I really do think it was a pseudo
religious experience that we were having
what ancient people and kind of
backwards people have the feeling that
they get when they go to church going to
church and singing songs I wanna call
them back with people but you know the
interesting thing about this is it was
actually Asian people yes oh I want to
say to you that the score of this was
done by harold faltermeyer the same guy
that wrote ax left for Beverly Hills Cop
yeah and it shows yeah it was good in it
also I think they liked the ending theme
song like the super cheesy that is
actually a little song well that was
actually done by John Parr and I think
that was the same guy that did the st.
Elmo's fire theme song right because
memory that was like a big hit in like
1985 that song like that song is also
80s as [ __ ] with the hair and
everything but this was directed by Paul
Michael Glaser and interestingly he was
like the first guy that was supposed to
do it then they fired him and then they
put another guy on and then they put
Paul Michael Michael Glaser back on and
actually on sports and Edgar's got a
record as saying that he didn't like
that guy's direction he thought he kind
of messed it up he's like he made it
look too much like made-for-tv movie
like it was I mean the direction is very
I've heard it called workman like yes
competent but it's there's nothing
flashy about it you know and some of the
shots I don't like the way they edited
some of the fights between the heroes
and them and the stalkers are real
simplistic they were very dark they were
you know far away and like not real
artfully done I guess yeah the actual
action of the fights themselves wasn't
the centerpiece of this movie not really
not what they were trying to do was more
of what was happening with the the
studio audience it was more plot driven
it wasn't so action driven I look what
another thing that I loved about this
movie too is that every time they show
shots of like the audience whether it's
like all the poor people in the street
watching it on the big screen or whether
it's this like crazy old people like in
the audience watching it
you're all super [ __ ] jazzed for yes
yeah and it's like I wondered if they
told them they said act like those
idiots on let's make a deal yeah like
everything is like way different today
you're like way too excited about
everything check with it's me I think
that's what they told them to do because
that's what they're I feel like they're
just like really like that and it's very
very funny yeah there's a there's a
bunch of mad shots in this too that
establishes the world as being basically
the same world as Blade Runner yeah it
was it would except not quite as
cool-looking yeah yeah but it was Tim's
trying to be like the old Blade Runner
when you looked at the skyline you know
like the big with the big tyrell
corporation-- building you know you can
kind of see buildings that look like
that in the background of the skyline
it's pretty cool but another thing too
is that and I wanted to get a little bit
into the differences between the movie
in the book I mean the movie it has the
same basic premise as in a game show
where you go on and then people hunt you
and kill you
but that's about it that's pretty much
the only things that are similar the
book which was written I think in 1982
written by Stephen King under his
Richard Bachman pseudonym the book is
actually much more has a much larger
scope now in the book Ben Richards is
nothing like Arnold Schwarzenegger he's
like a Reedy skinny like yeah everyman
they have one of those in the movie but
yeah his little side yeah he's like a
geeky character he was the one that had
to figure out you know the computer
stuff because you know he you know does
computers and stuff yeah you know how
that goes in the 80s they had a skinny
little glasses and stuff they were he's
like computer nerd this character type
but yeah the character of Ben Richards
in the book is very much like that and
he's actually not a criminal and the
show it's government-owned the TV
station but they don't have a thing
where it's like oh we put criminals on
there to execute them it's pretty much
anyone it's volunteer is what it is
because it's a huge prize so it's
actually more like real reality TV yeah
so the main character is really poor he
has a wife and kid in the book and he
volunteers to be on the show because if
you win no one's ever won you get a
billion dollar
yeah but you still get $100 for every
hour that you stay alive and $100 for
every cop or stalker they call them
hunters in the book that you kill okay
so he's basically volunteers beyond the
show because he's broke his [ __ ] right
and he's starving and his family is
starving and he's like okay well I'm
gonna be on this show and hopefully he's
like I know I'm probably not gonna win
but I'm hoping to accumulate enough
money so that his wife and kid can live
so there's no element of like
criminality or anything and the
different thing too is that in the book
there is no game arena right you can go
anywhere right but there are hunters
everywhere they're basically hitmen
they're not like you know glad they
don't have like wacky costumes right
yeah these have wacky yeah they're just
hitmen and also just regular people who
see you can get rewards if they tell
people where you are good so you pretty
much have to go everywhere in disguise
and [ __ ] like that I don't know should I
spoil the ending of the book the book I
know don't split those points okay yeah
it ends very very differently than how
the movie ends in the movie Arnold
Schwarzenegger is not a criminal though
he's actually a hero they made look like
a criminal yeah he was a military
chopper pilot some kind of attack
chopper pilot and he and his flight
group were ordered to go out suppress a
food riot and he refused to open up on
unarmed civilians down there so his own
crew attacked and attacked him and
arrested him and they basically sold him
off through government contracts to the
running man show and they rieta tada
video footage to make it look like
Arnold Schwarzenegger opened up on the
food riot crowd without orders in these
so they kind of show in the movie how
you can edit video to change a narrative
to make it look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger is character was
disobeying orders and opening up on the
on the crowd without permission which is
quite cool the way they did that there's
a lot of stuff in the movie that kind of
came to pass in a certain way like
Arnold Schwarzenegger buys a airline
ticket over a computer in in a house you
know
woman's house it looks like web TV it
looks very standard but I remember
seeing that as a kid going damn he
bought an airline ticket off of a
computer [ __ ] it is the future you know
there's this it's funny because you look
at you look at a lot of the themes and a
lot of the stuff that happens in running
man and it's supposed to be 2019 and
that time has come and gone you know
like the the dominance of cable
television is kind of a being right now
and you know there's no mention of
anything like an internet or a YouTube
yeah really I don't really know if any
book any movies predicted that nobody
predicted the Internet yeah or cell
phones or any yeah no not really not
really oh yeah you know what well not
say Dick Tracy's phone watch was a cell
phone with China with Skype on it
because in certain anything yeah that's
true
so you know that idea was kind of there
but if that was usually something it was
kind of radio / TV power yeah not really
something that came with you know with
an Internet the whole idea of an
internet really I didn't see any movies
the closest thing that I ever read and
this was in a book and [ __ ] wrong
yeah thing I ever read in a book that
came out like [ __ ] I can't remember when
the book came out was Ender's Game yeah
well I read the book and I think the
book came out in the late 60s and it
described something very much like an
internet like people were uploading you
know papers to essentially the cloud so
other people could read it and said that
was pretty much the closest thing I ever
read about but I you know I didn't read
a lot of sci-fi back in the day I was
mostly a horror girl but I remember
reading that and going wow that's very
internet like right but the thing about
it too and what you were saying about
reading the video they did the same
thing to Marina Conchita Alonso as
character she was actually she worked
for the network she just like was a
composer she wrote jingles and [ __ ] and
she got she got her hands on the
original edit yes she kind of started to
get sympathetic toward Ben Richards and
thinking maybe something was up so she
went and looked for the raw footage and
then she found out the truth and then
they put her on the game show - and the
thing that cracked me up about it was
that to make her look bad
like to make her look like a crow but
she slept with two or three men in the
same year like that yeah yeah yeah she
just stuck lied about me oh we're not
like we never lie on TV we never lie
it's like I said again richard dawson is
so good at this he's like so [ __ ]
smart me yeah he's just exact I'm a
because he is a game show hosted he was
like you know turned the crank up to
like super sleazy games because he was
already kind of sleazy I gotta admit
though that was kind of his gimmick
though he was expected to be a slime
ball back in back in the 70s in the 80s
you could grab some ass as long as he
had the right expression on your face
and you were famous he was getting away
with that [ __ ] yeah libraries got away
with that [ __ ] they did yeah yeah that
was funny uh yeah I guess
but I was gonna say to like the the book
was actually set in 2025 but I don't
know why they changed it to 20 and 19
for the I don't know I guess this movie
did kind of okay when it came out it
didn't make a huge amount of money it
costs 20 million to make and it made 37
million in the theaters so you know it
was an okay success it got pretty much
mixed reviews of like you know liked
thought it was kind of cheesy which it
was even at the time pretty much Richard
Dawson's character got pretty
universally praised cuz they're like man
look at that [ __ ] he's like
perfect ass thank you
but yeah you know like I said it's this
is one that's kind of forgotten I mean I
hadn't forgot about it because I saw it
a [ __ ] ton of times he was on cable a
million times back in the 80s and I
think now that you mentioned it I think
I might have seen this in the theater
too because it was a Stephen King
adaptation and I generally would go and
see all of those you know and I and I
did like this book I think I read the
book before I saw them maybe the
addition of DVDs that I have can't came
with two discs and one of them was like
a regular format I guess it was
something you'd watch on an old CRT
television and it looked like crap on on
my smart TV but the widescreen version
looked pretty good and that's the best
I've seen this movie since the theater
and I had seen it a couple times like
you said on on regular television CRT
television like on cable orth on VHS and
it looked bad but it it looks a lot
better in widescreen in HD probably look
pretty good
on blu-ray but there's always gonna be
limitations in this movie just because
of the the sets you know the sets are
not impressive by today's standards
although they were back then you know I
remember this movie being a big deal to
see it in the theater like that that's
pretty good movie yeah yeah big budget
movie you know that's way we well it was
a big budget for this yeah I'm yeah and
I mean like I said I think a great a
great deal of it took place in the you
know gameshow studio yeah or it was shot
like outside in the quote-unquote game
zone which was just like alleys and [ __ ]
alleys and factories yes so it's like I
said it's not a thing where like Blade
Runner where it's it has just this whole
world that like envelops you they try
and they really try yeah this one yeah
this one they you can tell that they
tried to get that but they didn't really
I mean like I said they were matte
paintings yeah the director didn't
really have the bus super artistic I
maybe not budget the budget or you know
maybe the budget wasn't spent on that
yeah and some of the stuff like the
hunter killers what were they called
again
the stalkers their costumes were kind of
cheesy looking especially dinamo with
all the little Christmas lights
although schwarzenegger does you know
call him a christmas tree you know then
he had a damn flag mohawk on his helmet
to protect his robot ball hawk
underneath yeah he had a real plastic
protective motor hawk over it so yeah
well you need to pre kappa chicken bog
yeah and he was riding around in this
combat vehicle that looked like a VW Bug
kind of cut down and I remember it
looked being really cool in the day you
look at it now and you just kind of
laugh it's pretty much like a modified
yeah dude by the exhaust car the
motorcycles they showed we're still
pretty cool yeah there was there's a
motorcycle that chainsaw holds up over
it or bus holds up over his head and
drops it I still really can't identify
that motorcycle it's got a weird frame
it's some kind of an enduro you know
real high-tech at the time when I saw it
I was very impressed with it you know
the way that motorcycle I see it now
it's some kind of custom job I think if
somebody they probably like kitted it
out to make it look ya juristic for the
movie yeah and that frame I don't know
if that frame actually came off of a
dirt bike you know maybe somebody in the
audience might know that
motorcycle but the hi pipe on it and
everything is pretty neat the sauce
dirtbikes with the extended swing arms
which was very unusual for that time you
look at it now and you see and you see a
lot of extended swing arms so can we
talk about the weird scene with dynamo
at the end where he pretty much like
straight up attempts to rape baby could
she don't love this character with these
[ __ ] tighty whities yeah like all
this Christmas tree [ __ ] on the top and
then they pull back at the shot and I'm
like oh oh no I remember thinking it was
awesome when I saw it at the theater
because what it does it underlines the
the moral corruption of the moral decay
of people yeah like this guy was
supposed to be a superstar on television
do you know that and then he's just like
trains just damn rapist yes like in
hallway yeah see studio I was thinking
singing opera yeah yeah at the time I
just thought it was just they were just
trying to expose kind of like the moral
decay of society yeah I guess that's
what they were talking about although
and I want to make mention to you how
funny it was when I mean Arnold
Schwarzenegger pretty much he kind of
breaks into Maria Conchita Alonso I keep
saying that her her character's name is
Amber but he said he breaks into Amber's
apartment yeah well he thinks it's his
brother's apartment so he didn't like
straight-up break in there but what he
gets in there
he pretty much ties her up yeah you'll
drop the funniest thing though is that
she has quote-unquote contraband in her
apartment its cassette tape and it's
contraband I'm like yeah I remember when
we had all those cassette tapes yeah
yeah and he uses web TV to buy that
biplane yeah it's just so much in her
credit card seriously can we think of an
80s movie that accurately predicted the
future no no I can't think of one
it was almost it's really sad because
all they did was take like 80s
technology and be like let's just do
more of that yeah but they didn't really
go that far they didn't really they
couldn't take the names get that you
can't even say alien 1 and alien 2 were
accurate with me because that was
actually in our future still yeah
the television screens were still CRT in
the cat it's pretty big and it's just
know they convey things I mean here's
the thing this is why I hard to get the
future right yeah especially the Antep
you know the budget especially the
generation of people that are writing
these movies you know these are writers
they're not scientists they don't
understand the impact of technology so
once you have internet there's a lot of
other things that become obsolete you
know like okay in running many orders of
plane take it off a basically web TV but
there's also cable TV going on and
there's also cassette tape yeah that
doesn't all survive side by side past
what 1990 I mean even in 87 cassette
tapes were kind of on the way out
right so they should have kind of
perceived them right because they showed
a sneak peak of DVD technology in
Robocop and Robocop I believe predates
running man yeah that the bad guy pulls
out a CD oh that's right puts it in a
player and it becomes video and people
back then we're probably like oh all
right yeah when I first saw that I just
what we knew about laserdisc trade I
said it's mini laserdisc that's how I
interpret it yeah
good they did have those yeah I worked
in a record store in 1993 and they were
everyone was trying to make laserdisc
happen yeah so we had to have we had
like a rack and it had like three rows
of laserdisc in there and the whole time
I worked there nobody ever ever bought
was it was way it's time and they didn't
have like a huge selection of movies it
was pretty much just where their famous
ones and they had it in the 70s late 70s
yeah I remember and the player was
probably close to $2,000 in the late 70s
and then a disc was over $100 for a
movie so who would spend a move should I
remember when VHS tapes were like $89
yeah and and when V when VCRs were like
a grand yeah do you remember that I
remember that yeah that was a long time
ago but yeah it's like I don't know and
we talked about this a live said this is
why if I was gonna you know if somebody
gave me several million dollars to make
a movie I would never ever make a sci-fi
movie because you can't extrapolate far
enough forward you either have to
extrapolate far enough forward that all
civilization is crashed and you going
back to the caveman days you can do that
or you make something that's just like
so weird and out there
that it's not gonna be tied back to
something because if you just make like
I said a lot of sci-fi movies that they
made in the 80s they're pretty much just
like well take a cassette tape but make
it bigger or take it you know what I
mean it's just they didn't really have
much of a vision of what the future was
gonna look like which is why none of
them ever got it right and you know it's
gonna look dated yeah some of them less
than others you know I just feel like if
we're gonna do a sci-fi movie don't
concentrate on technology because it's
gonna look like [ __ ] in like five or ten
years tell you the most believable
portrayal of some kind of a weird
futuristic technologies the technology
that the engineers have in prometheus
and alien covenant which it's not even
digital yeah digital it hadn't even
occurred to them it was just some kind
of weird analog biology based technology
yeah where the ship's just looks like
it's grown yeah that's kind that was a
good choice yeah because you can't I
mean that's not gonna look dated ever no
well I don't think so but you know what
I mean yeah an image might come down if
a bunch of stars and a star map in a
room but you don't really know how it
was done that's what I mean you have to
have some level of like mysticism to it
is I think the direction you want to go
in because otherwise if you just have
you know it's gonna look like wargames
and a couple here it's gonna be like a
little bitty like apple 2e or something
like that going who is hacking into
NORAD yeah this [ __ ] big chunky
desktop computer but yeah so the same
thing happened with this but you know if
that happens with all babies movies well
it's a fun movie anyway though it's very
fun that the movie is about it's cheesy
as [ __ ] if you love 80s movie it's
action-packed the editing gives a very
driving tempo to the movie yeah it's
pretty fast-paced yeah it's one thing
after another and there's really there
isn't any downtime in the movie really
some of these old movies I'm getting
into old movies I really like 80s and
90s movies some of them were kind of
some of them drags some of them were
kind of difficult to watch you can tell
there's a lot of filler in some of them
but not this one this one moves you
along at a good pace and it's
entertaining throughout this doesn't
this doesn't really have any no doesn't
have it there's no boring in this movie
and unfortunately some are on swartz
negra movies you know like raw deal and
red heat did have for either boring
parts of it or tonal problems in the
movie
yeah you were talking about red hate the
other day well I like to read he that
could have been a really good movie it's
just that the tone was kind of incorrect
it didn't know if it was gonna be a
comedy or if it was gonna be serious it
tried to do both at the same time it
didn't really work I haven't seen that
movie in a long time I remember not
early like it and all that much it was a
high quality movie just like I said the
tone wasn't correct
it could have been reacted I think a
soundtrack and an editing could have
fixed it also can I say in the running
man there was an actor in this who was a
very minor role I guess he played one of
the guys that worked at the TV studio
and the actor's name is Roger Bumpass I
just saw that on the Wikipedia page and
I'm like oh god this gotta be a screen
name but why did you change it to that
unless you were a porn star it was just
Rodger Bumpass alright bumping people's
ass these guys were all coming out of
the 70s and 80s back when when a
talk-show host could grab your wife's
ass and could get away with it cuz he
had a drink in his other hand people
just think it was funny yeah so if
you're into cheesy 80s action movies
like we are in a few like Arnold
Schwarzenegger then you'll probably like
this one like I said it's very very very
different than the novel you know it's a
lot more comedic novel was a lot more
dystopian and dark and all the other
[ __ ] and like I said had a much larger
scope but you know it's this is still
like a really fun movie you get to see
yeah Jesse the body Ventura wearing a
really cheap like robot is definitely
what is that
definitely definitely in the top five of
Arnold Schwarzenegger's movies it does
have its own quality you know you're not
talking about predator t1 or Conan you
know but it's good
oh this was written by the same guy that
wrote commando I think yeah I like same
strain writer yeah I would put this kind
of like on the same level as pretty
close to Total Recall the original yeah
it has a similar kind of like that
similar kind of oh yeah yeah before we
go tell someone to mention that due to
the response of our 100th episode we're
going to do the news and video yeah
we're gonna do like the opening segment
and the news you know how we usually do
shoutouts and news and every
we're gonna do that in video I don't
want to do the whole row in video
because those files are so big and
because it's yeah it's like very
labor-intensive yeah and if you had an
hour-long show I mean it becomes a
full-time job to do those that each week
along with the movie reviews so we're
gonna mention this again because not
everybody watches our movie reviews but
in the next upcoming episode we're gonna
mention it again but to get this done
right we have to get chroma key
background and we all gotta get the
lighting and we're gonna get a better
audio system to try to improve the
quality of the show because we think the
channel will grow larger if we at least
put the news in video and to give you
guys something to look at so people can
kind of make a connection with us and
the channel will grow a bit larger once
a channel kind of gross and we're
talking about you know $1,500 a month
patreon we can actually talk about maybe
expanding to multiple shows a week yeah
we have been talking about maybe doing
more than one shot mean we do two shows
a week obviously but doing more than
that and we could probably do more than
that on other subjects now the reason
why we haven't done this so far of
course is a Jenni's main income is books
and a graphic design graphic design so
she's got to get books written and you
know you guys like the books too and
books once they're written they make
money forever so books are high priority
but you know we can work something out
with the time and once once the trilogy
is finished for faithless Melanie hates
this villain you know we could might be
able to expand the show out to some
extra stuff you know we considered doing
what kind like a comedy cooking thing we
you know there's a lot of little things
that we're thinking about maybe doing
the movie reviews in a different way to
where there's more of a video element to
me yeah we definitely want to establish
more of it I'm like we don't have super
great equipment right now we are gonna
start doing little bits of video like
slowly incorporating little bits of
video into the regular show and then
over the coming months we're going to
invest in better audio equipment we're
gonna get a chroma key background we're
gonna get better video but you know
better lighting and stuff like that so
just because we have such a good
response to our hundredth episode even
though you know the video is kind of
like you know just kind of done on the
fly yeah we had to like bump the
resolution down
because the the file was so huge for
three hours of it a YouTube wouldn't
take yeah they would so you're seeing it
pretty bad it was it looked a lot better
before we reduced the resolution on it
yeah but so that's definitely something
that we want to do and like I said after
this year when we're getting into 2019
after I finished my faceless villain
trilogy which I hope to have done by the
end of this year we definitely want to
look into maybe expanding the show out
and we've been throwing around different
ideas like that you know the main show
is gonna stay the same the movie reviews
you know we might do some others just
incorporate more video in them and stuff
like that and then maybe we might do
another type of show like you said we
talked about doing like cooking show or
like comedy more funny type stuff yeah
we know a lot of people we got a lot of
friends that you guys would really enjoy
pride meeting you know we've even
thought about maybe doing board games
with everybody there or you know yeah
just having guests on you know on on
different shows I'm like yeah maybe
interviews you know something we've been
talking and Jennie and I have been
discussing this among among ourselves
for months now of expanding it but the
trilogy has to get done before that cuz
that's gonna take up a lot of time then
we have to see what the response of the
trilogy is and I mean ideally if the
show generated two grand a month patreon
money we could focus on this a lot more
yeah downside of it is that when the
show's gone the money's gone with books
when you get a book written it's out
there making money forever until you die
yeah it's like a good retirement program
so like I said that's kind of the main
priority for there at least for the
remainder of this year until that
trilogy is another option is whether or
not we were just maybe to hire somebody
to come in and do all the engineering
for the show yes so you can just write a
book if we had a big response that would
could be possible yeah that way we just
record the show and then you write books
you might give them and they you know we
have the facilities here to where
somebody can just do all the video
editing for us you know but if you're
making three four shows a week that's a
full-time job yeah it's a full-time job
that do editing all that audio and all
that video but yeah it's just something
something that is probably coming in the
future yeah so this is a little bit of
bonus content for this video but like I
said we starting with f
1:01 we will be incorporating a little
bit of video at the beginning of the
show like just on the new segment stuff
all right that'll do it for this latest
movie review remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe and share
on all your social media tell all your
friends about us and also if you'd like
to financially support the show we have
a patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also be
sure to check out our regular episodes
which come out every Tuesday our
hundredth episode just came out this
past Tuesday it was three hours long so
I got watch it if you have it and our
movie reviews come out every Friday see
you next time bye